想要孩子是正常的，
至于说将来万一实在不能生，
要分开的话，
大家也可以客客气气的分开，
但你不能在你30岁还没有到的时候，
先假想我将来不能生孩子，
我现在就跟你谈我要分开，
矫情，
我自己是97年，
我老公是93年的，
结婚三年，
我们目前最大的一个问题就是生小孩子的一个问题，
因为我们结婚之后没有能够生利生小孩，
我们就进行了试管，
不能自然怀孕的原因是什么？
是他还是你，
应该问题在于我，
因为我们在刚结婚的时候经历了一次宫外，
我有一侧的输卵管进行了一个基除试管，
三次的话，
有两次是成功，
但是最后是属于停了，
心跳停了，
这两次失败的话，
对我个人的打击还是比较大的，
我就不想再去进行这个试管了，
我老公那边就是他觉得你不想去也可以，
那我们尝试看未来有没有可能做宝贝能够做回来，
但是我婆婆呢，
她就是非常想让我们生一个小孩，
但是我婆婆这个人她是非常的好，
从我嫁到这边来之后，
在家里是从来不需要我做任何一点家务，
平常过年过生日他都是给我钱，
等于事儿也做，
人也不小气的这种，
因为我是在长沙，
我老公目前因为工作的原因，
他要在外地出差，
出差的时间可能会比较长，
或许是一年或。
其实两年这个不一定，
我老公他希望我能够去他的城市，
我们两个人在那边生活，
因为这个问题在进行一个纠结，
那你在你的这个城市的工作是公家饭吗？
铁饭碗吗？
不是是很喜欢的工作吗？
我目前其实是大概的一个状态，
我刚刚辞职，
那两口子感情好也可以去啊，
你去了那边再找工作呗。
其实是有一点我很纠结，
因为我明白我婆婆虽然对我很好，
但是如果我一直不生小孩，
我婆婆她对这个东西应该是会有很大的一个意见嘛，
她希望我生小孩，
比如说春节她就追我，
她就希望我再去做检查，
有问题解决问题。
但是我个人的话，
因为质卵的问题，
我个人对小孩子产生了一种很抵触的一个心忆，
我觉得你还年轻啊，
你是97年的，
还不到30岁，
不到30岁，
你只是一侧输卵管切除了，
还有另一侧输卵管，
你自怀的概率也是挺大的，
所以这个事情的话，
接纳自己现在有抵触，
如果你现在不想生的话，
你该做避孕措施就做避孕措施，
至于说他妈妈有什么期待，
有什么希望，
这个东西是老人他我们也控制不了，
这是人家自然有的一个想法，
理解他，
同时也不会说去抗拒或者干嘛的，
他要说我配合，
我该去医院体检，
当然不是为了光为了生小孩了，
也是为了我自己的健康呀。
的妇科呀，
我的各方面的营养成分怎么样啊？
我的身体条件怎么样啊，
也是为了我自己的健康，
我当然可以配合去检查了，
我没有任何问题啊，
你现在30岁都不到，
你应该做的是，
如果两口子感情好，
且他也非常渴望你过去，
且你在现在这个地方也没有工作，
也在待业的话，
高高兴兴的过去了，
换个环境，
换个心情了，
婆婆不在身边，
或许没有压力了之后还能自怀哦，
高兴的过日子喽，
现在又没有小孩，
周末一起去看电影了，
去爬山了，
去游泳了，
去健身了，
老人又不在身边，
两口子想在家做在家做了，
想吃外卖就点那种有实体店的相对干净一点的外卖咯，
先过几年好日子了。
其实您说的这个我也是考虑过，
但是有个问题，
我觉得我自身的一个情况，
因为之前做试管各种折腾，
导致我现在其实我个人觉得自怀的可能性并不大，
我也试探过我老公的想法，
我说如果我们以后就不生小孩，
你觉得我们俩的婚姻能不能过得下去，
他就没有去回答我这个问题，
我觉得如果说我在这个婚姻里面的价值仅仅是生小孩子这一个问题，
那我是在想我要不要直接就分开，
我的意思就跟他说，
如果你真的非常想要孩子，
那我觉得要不然我们现在趁大家情绪都还比较稳定的时候去分开，
我可能会想这种问题，
我万事都会想的比较悲观，
矫情，
真的太矫情了。
你这个思想方式就是说，
到底你是爱我还是爱我的子宫，
难道我的价值，
难道你对我的爱就只是因为我生孩子，
会生孩子你才爱我吗？
太矫情了，
这种想法，
普通人过日子啊，
不要那么矫情，
真的，
普通人过日子就看看他是不是一个善良的人，
是不是一个正常的人，
他是不是关心我，
牵挂我，
是不是愿意为我付出，
愿意跟我在一起就已经很好了。
换位思考一下，
他想要孩子是正常的，
他想要孩子不是什么罪孽，
不是什么罪过，
他想要孩子是正常的。
至于说将来万一实在不能生，
要分开的话，
大家也可以客客气气的分开，
但你不能在你30岁还没有到的时候，
先假想我将来不能生孩子，
我现在就跟你谈我要分开，
矫情我菲姐，
其实我想这个问题不是说我要确定他爱不爱我，
或者是说他是不是看中我生孩子这个能力，
是因为我觉得我婆婆对我非常的好，
我也非常能够理解他们家想要生孩子的这个情况，
因为我老公30岁才结婚，
他们对这个事情很着急，
我老公日常也是对我非常的好，
所以我从这个角度去考虑，
如果说他们对我非趁好，
但我自己现在对这个事情又很抵触，
我每次面对他们的时候，
有的时候会内心感到好像有一种很内疚的感觉，
但是我又不想强迫自己再去通过试管这种方式去做这个事情，
尊重自。
你不想去做试管的话，
那咱们就自怀了，
自怀又不是说我所有的卵子都生产不了了，
又不是说我的输卵管都被切除掉了，
又不是说我的子宫被摘除掉了，
我现在还是有自怀的可能的，
对不对？
人生不能因为说我将来可能会死，
所以我今天就不活了，
咱们人生不是这样的逻辑，
不是说我可能将来怀不了孩子，
所以我现在就跟我爱的人分开了。
人生是我跟我爱的人在一起我就赚一天，
在一起两天我就赚两天，
我跟我爱的男人多吃一顿饭，
我就赚一顿饭。
人生应该是这种态度，
而不是说将来因为我会死，
所以我今天干脆别活了，
因为我怕我将来可能生不了孩子，
所以我现在对于一个对我好的婆婆，
对我好的老公，
我不要了，
多可笑，
不明白你的意思，
婆婆对你好，
我就接纳，
你对我好啊，
愿意给我炖猪蹄儿我就吃猪蹄儿，
愿意给我炖羊汤我就吃羊汤，
愿意给我炖什么滋补的产品我就吃，
我把自己养的壮壮的，
身体好好的，
气血好好的，
即便我不生孩子，
我是不是趁着一个好婆婆我得了一个好身体，
趁我也赚了我老公她希望我去她的城市，
如果说我在我自己这个城市没有特别好的工作或怎么样，
其实你的这是觉得是可以过去的，
可以啊，
反正你在这个城市也没有好过工作是不是？
那趁着年轻两口子好好的过日子，
趁着没有孩子，
婆婆又不在身边，
两口子怎么打滚爱怎么四仰八叉，
怎么四仰八叉爱？
啥干点啥多好啊，
好的我明白了，
我没有其他问题了，
希望你能听进去，
姐妹你这多好呀，
婆婆也不错，
老公也不错，
现在又没有什么压力，
你30岁都不到，
这日子有多少人想跟你换着过呀？
好的我明白了，
好就这样啊，
拜拜，
搞得我都流口水了，
如果婆婆天天做饭洗衣服，
打扫卫生的话，
好不好？
刚才有个朋友说很理解刚才这个姐妹，
我曾经也有跟你相同类似的情况，
到最后怀孕了，
祝你好孕，
她只是现在有这个可能啊，
两次的试管的这样一个失败，
可能对他的心理造成了一定的影响，
那在这种情况下，
龙飞姐就多说几句话，
也可以去接受一些心理的治疗，
多跟一些心理咨询师啊，
心理这方面的老师去聊，
就像我们有的怀孕生孩子了之后，
会进入一种产后抑郁的状态，
那同样虽然说没有成功，
可能对身体的损伤没有那么大，
像怀孕生孩子激素没有的相差那么大，
但是对人的心理也会造成一点影响的。
刚才那个妹妹的话，
你去了跟老公在那边好好的过日子，
调整自己的身体和心情啊，
如果觉得心情还是不太好的话，
还是容易找茬儿，
容易担忧未来，
容易焦虑的话，
那就找心理咨询师多去聊一聊，
不到30岁的年纪就开始担忧自己将来能不能生孩子这个事儿的话，
是有点过度焦虑了，
记得点赞关注哦。